professor uh i don't want to keep you
too much longer but i did want to get
your thoughts on
you know some of the debates you
participated in over the years
uh with william f buckley with foucault
and so many others that still are so
watched
on youtube and other platforms today and
thinking back
to them now what stands out about them
what
what do you remember what seems to you
to to be notable about them as
as somebody who participated in them and
was there in the room for many of those
conversations
well they're different a foucault
serious person we were talking about
real issues
you can have an opinion on them but with
buckley it was quite different
my impression of buckley was that he was
just a fraud
i mean he had a nice style
you know he spoke as if he knew what he
was talking
about as soon as you begin you look at
the debate you can see it
as soon as you get into any particular
issue
it quickly changes the subject because
he basically doesn't know anything about
it
and try to overwhelm you with his uh
rhetorical style and so on i thought he
was all
surface in fact you couldn't see it in
the debate
but at the end he was so infuriated
that he he left the studio
screaming at me saying you know
have you back and show you a thing or
two or something like that
that wasn't recorded but my impression
of him was
that if he just kept calm and quiet and
tried to talk about him
within about issues it would collapse
what was was foucault or are there
others that in thinking back you say
this is someone who challenged me not
just rhetorically but really
substantively this was really where i
was the most
challenged
well it was we disagreed on a number of
things
but at least we were talking about real
issues
i should say that there's a little
background to that
uh foucault i i don't
know any any french who code doesn't
speak english
but we spent the afternoon together
before the debate
just walking around the dutch
countryside
uh partly just because we wanted to talk
to each other
informally but partly to see if we could
get by
with him talking french and me talking
english
and or did we need a translator so we
figured we could
kind of make it with and
we decided to wing it and do it without
a translator which
sort of worked but